- [Mark] All right, Elizabeth.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Elizabeth, where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- [Elizabeth] Olive Branch, Mississippi.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- [Elizabeth] I did to start off with.
My dad left, you know, when
I was around two or three,
four or five, I guess.
He kept coming around for a little bit
and I was actually molested
by my dad from about three to six.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- Other than that, I had
a, my mom she's a nurse.
I had a good childhood.
I was raised, you know, my
mom and my grandparents.
Things were pretty good, pretty normal,
you know, other than my dad.
And then he left and
stayed gone, you know.
I still to this day, don't
see him, you know, very often.
I remember like riding
four wheelers, you know,
and just grew up out in the
country, everything normal.
I went to school, everything was good
but I always remember
feeling like I wasn't enough.
It wasn't-
- [Mark] Did you have
that feeling before you
were raped, molested or
did it start after that?
- I think it started after
that, more when I grew
into my teenage years, yeah.
- [Mark] Did you ever confront your dad
or say anything to your mom or anybody?
- I did to my mom when
I was 18 and, you know,
she didn't know.
I mean, and you know by then my thing is,
I don't live to hate
anybody, so I don't hate him.
I forgive him. I have to
remember he's sick too.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Especially with me being
like this, like I know
that you know, we all deal
with some kind of demons.
- [Mark] Yeah. And then how
far do you go in school?
- I went to, my 11th
grade year I dropped out
and then I got a GED and
I did a year of college,
a year of nursing school, actually.
And then I had my first
son which is Landon
and I wanted to stay at home with him.
So, I stayed at home with him.
His dad was a plumber, you know,
and he took care of everything.
Even though we did drugs, I
stayed at home with my child
and did 'em, you know, and
I know that sounds horrible
but that's-
- [Mark] How the drugs
come into your life?
- I think being around the
wrong people, you know,
the people your mom and them
tell you to stay away from.
They were older than me and
they were doing something
and I wanted to know what it was like.
- [Mark] Yeah. Did you
find that the drugs kind
of numb the pain of what
you went through as a child?
- They do. They do.
It numbs every, well it
did, it numbed everything.
- [Mark] Made everything okay?
- It made everything okay.
Made everything normal.
Everybody was happy or I was happy,
you know, I thought that-
- [Mark] Yeah.
- In reality, it's miserable.
- Miserable.
- [Mark] And then how did
prostitution come into your life?
- I've always had my
son's dad to take care
of me and to take care of everything.
Right at two years ago, he
passed away from an overdose.
And that's when I actually
started prostitution.
- [Mark] Because he needed the money?
- Because I needed the
money to support my habit.
- [Mark] And your son?
- Well, in actuality I
don't take care of my son.
- [Mark] Oh, where is he?
- He's with my mom.
Sorry. It's okay.
I don't wanna talk about that, sorry.
- [Mark] So sex work started for you
and you worked on your own or with a pimp?
- I started with a pimp
and I saw that I was giving
these people way more money
then what I was getting out of it.
I mean, I wasn't getting
literally anything but drugs.
I wasn't being taken care of
in any type of way, you know.
I was still struggling by myself,
so I decided I was gonna go struggle
by myself and not come into Midtown.
And I just started on my own.
But you still, you still
had to pay for protection
you know, you have to have
a place to stay every night.
- [Mark] Were you able to get away
from that pimp relationship?
- I was, it was actually, he,
still to this day I deal with him
and I still have to pay him
when I see him and stuff
but I was actually able to leave.
- [Mark] How did you do that?
- I just walked away one day and,
you know, I got,
I was kidnapped over
it and raped and beat.
And after that, nothing, you know.
- [Mark] But you still
continue to pay him today?
Just because you're in his territory, or?
- When I'm in his territory, yes.
- [Mark] And the guys that, your customers
the guys that pay you, they
treat you nicely, they're,
how do you get treated by them?
- Most of them do.
You know, you have some that,
they take advantage of this situation.
They will rape you, they will
take your money, you know.
- [Mark] Do you get depressed sometimes?
- Do I get depressed? I stay depressed.
And that's why I still, you
know, I do the heroin now
'cause my body physically has to have it.
But, it's like the more I do
the more miserable I am, you know,
it's like a never ending
cycle of just madness.
- [Mark] And are you making enough money
to support yourself or your habits?
- Most of the time I do.
Sometimes I don't, you know,
sometimes I don't have a place to stay.
Sometimes I don't have all the dubs
that I need to keep me
well through the day.
I mean, it just depends.
I do pretty well, most of the time.
- [Mark] And do you still
have contact with your family?
- I do. I do.
- [Mark] They know what
you're going through and?
- Yeah. Well, I mean they know
but we don't talk about it like, you know.
It was always in my household,
when there's a problem,
you push it under the rug
and it just goes away.
But this is not going away, you know.
This is real, true life.
- [Mark] Do you see a way out?
- Right now, honestly no.
- [Mark] So you have one child, right?
- I have two children.
I have a 19 month old
that was adopted by a family in Memphis.
- [Mark] And who is the
father of your second child?
- He used to be a customer of mine.
And we actually got into a relationship
but it was just not, not a good situation,
you know, very bad enabler.
Very controlling, you know.
In one form or another,
I'm always getting beat on
or raped or, you know, just-
- [Mark] It must be hard,
'cause everyone in your life
is trying to take advantage of you?
- That's how, yes. That's how I've-
- [Mark] They're just using
you one way or another.
- Pretty much.
- [Mark] And that's gotta
undermine your self worth on top
of what you've already went
through as a young girl?
- [Elizabeth] Right.
- [Mark] Right?
What helps you survive this?
- [Elizabeth] What?
- [Mark] You must be very
strong to continue doing this.
What helps you survive it?
- [Elizabeth] I honestly don't know.
The thought of my child
living with no parents,
that's my only thing.
I mean, 'cause I still see him and stuff,
you know, just about every weekend.
But just the thought of, you know,
losing his dad was enough.
What if he lost both of us?
But if I don't get off of this,
he might as well not have
me because I'm not there.
- [Mark] You've been arrested before?
- [Elizabeth] Yes, once for a DUI.
Other than that, I try
to stay out of the way.
I respect 'em, they have a job to do.
And that's what they're doing.
And I'm doing something wrong.
- [Mark] How much do you make in a day?
- [Elizabeth] Anywhere from 250 to $1,500.
- [Mark] On a good night, you making 1500.
You end up keeping how much of that?
- I mean, what do you mean, after-
- [Mark] Like you're giving
away some of it to the pimp.
- I mean, I don't go give him, you know,
say out of 1500, he might get two, 200.
- [Mark] Yeah. So that's fairly
good money on a good night.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And yet you're still struggling?
- I mean, I have a $300
a day dope habit, almost.
Right now, that means-
- [Mark] You gotta keep that up.
And then, you know, a place
to live, you know, food.
Some days we go without eating.
Some days I don't make
anything if I don't feel,
you know, I don't make anything.
- [Mark] How do you feel
like this has changed you?
This life, working the streets and-
- I feel like it has broke me as a person.
I feel less than even
more than I did before.
I feel very, I feel like I'm
just existing in this world.
- [Mark] How do you feel about
the, the men that pay you?
Do you respect them?
Are they good guys or you just-
- I just do my job.
- [Mark] You're just using
them and they're using you?
- Right.
- [Mark] What advice would
you give to someone else
that's in your situation
and considering doing
this kind of work?
- Don't. Don't.
Anything has to be better than this.
Like, I mean, what comes along with it?
The abuse, you know, when I was directly
with the pimp, if I were to make $1,500
I would've had to take it directly to him.
- [Mark] All of it?
- All of it, right.
You know, don't, that's
all I can say is, don't.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- I think to watch out for yourself
because nobody's gonna
watch out for you like you.
You know, value your family.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 30.
- [Mark] What's your biggest
regret, losing your kids?
- Yes, I have two actually.
My son's dad dying due to drug, you know.
I wish I had of been there.
I wish I could have stopped it.
Having to give my child up for adoption.
- [Mark] It's gotta be so
hard for a mother, right?
- And my other son and having, you know,
losing his dad and me being out here.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
the, the sexual abuse
as a child kind of set the whole chain
of destruction's, got
that started for you?
Led to the drug addiction,
led to the sex work,
led to the situation you're in right now?
- Maybe some of it,
or maybe me not dealing
with it, you know, did.
- [Mark] It's a lot to deal with.
- You know, they tried
to work me through it
when I was younger.
And I think if I would have
done it, you know, maybe.
- [Mark] You think
therapy might've helped?
- Maybe.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- Yeah.
If I would've been keen
to actually, you know,
stuck with it and not let that make me
as a person because that's not who I am.
That's just what I've been through.
- [Mark] All right,
Elizabeth, thank you so much
for sharing your story and
I wish you the best of luck
with everything you're going through.
- [Elizabeth] Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.